joe biden makes excuses for protesters
following a democratic senator into a
bathroom and facebook goes down for six
hours while the media prepare a full
frontal assault on the company in order
to suppress conservative information of
course i'm bench bureau this is the
bench bureau show
today's show is sponsored by expressvpn
stand up for your digital rights take
action at expressvpn.com
slash ben will get all the news in just
one moment first here is your reminder
you're paying way too much money for
your cell phone coverage and if you
think to yourself well you know i need
to because i have verizon or att or
t-mobile and those companies have really
good coverage here's the thing you can
get the same coverage as one of the
giant companies and save yourself a
bunch of money in the process instead of
paying for all of those companies and
their thousands of retail stores and
their added perks that you never use
pure talk usa will save you from all of
that they're not charging you for any of
that garbage instead they give you
killer 5g coverage on the same 5g
network as one of the big guys for about
half the cost the average family is
saving over 800 a year so what exactly
is your excuse i made the switch you can
keep your number keep your phone or get
huge discounts on the latest iphones and
androids get unlimited talk text and six
gigs of data for just 30 a month and
listen if you still want unlimited data
you can still get that and save a
fortune over the other guys go to
puretalk.com shop for the plan that's
right for you
they have a 30-day risk-free guarantee
so you literally have nothing to lose go
to puretalk.com enter promo code shapiro
you will save 50 off your very first
month of coverage that is puretalk.com
promo code shapiro puretalk is simply
smarter wireless already so as i have
suggested the democrats eventually will
get to some sort of agreement on
spending here i think it is very
unlikely they come to no agreement with
regard to spending but that agreement is
going to look a lot more like what joe
manchin wants than like what the squad
wants it's going to end up being about
two trillion dollars this is something
that president biden is now saying
according to politico biden summoned
progressives to a virtual meeting to
deliver a simple message praise senior
white house official he told them the
end point would be about two trillion
dollars he wanted their input on what
that should look like and so he's saying
i'm going to go with cinema mansion
because i really have no choice but i'm
going to let you guys write large suaves
of the bill it was part of a week-long
project by biden speaker nancy pelosi
and senate majority leader chuck schumer
to gradually let it sink in with
liberals the reconciliation bill really
will be dramatically scaled back now
remember we're still talking about
spending over three trillion dollars
right between this two trillion dollar
spending bill which undoubtedly will be
closer to 3 trillion when you kick in
all of the perks and you get rid of all
of the games
the course of gaming of the accounting
systems
when you add that together with the 1.2
trillion dollars that's going to be
spent on this infrastructure boondoggle
package you're talking about spending
again three trillion dollars that's
after joe biden earlier this year spent
two trillion dollars on the so-called
american jobs plan so that is a lot a
lot a lot of money but it's being
treated as though it's sort of a
moderate concession to go to two
trillion dollars
i'm old enough to remember when it was a
big deal with the federal government
every year was spending four trillion
dollars now we're spending five six
seven trillion dollars and everybody's
like wow look how moderate we are look
how much we've slowed this trade
uh-huh well the the real issue inside
the democratic party of course is that
there is a boiling battle between the
far left and the so-called moderate
caucus
and it is causing all sorts of chaos
inside the democratic party because joe
biden all of his sympathies are with the
radicals but the practicalities are with
the moderates and if joe biden actually
wanted to get a lot of things done he
should have come out earlier and just
endorsed the moderate position and then
put a lot of pressures on the
progressives instead he put a lot of
pressure on the moderates it went
nowhere and now he's being forced to go
back to the progressives and basically
beg them for their help the democrats
meanwhile are trying to proclaim that
they're getting things done and it's
only the republicans were obstructing
things jamie harrison the head of the
dnc was on with msnbc's stephanie rule
and he says that the new slogan for the
democrats is that democrats deliver and
republicans obstruct yeah that's not
going to work guys especially because
the stuff you're delivering is stuff
that pretty much nobody is demanding
here is the the head of the dnc jamie
harrison
we deliver for the american people that
is our message going in 2022 democrats
deliver republicans obstruct
democrats are the ones who do set these
deadlines though they're trying to
protect the the tax cut for jeff bezos
where we're just trying to get the mom
and pop shops on on main street to make
sure that they still republicans are not
in power
you are
okay and that in the end is going to be
the problem for the democrats because
they either own passing a giant
boondoggle package that involves massive
tax increases that are going to hamper
the economic recovery or they don't pass
it and they look like obstructionists so
it's a real problem for the democratic
party now what you'll hear from the
media the drum beat for the next couple
of weeks as the democrats start to put
together this two trillion dollar
package is that every element is super
popular on its own well that's always
true because if you ask americans about
free stuff they will always tell you yes
and then you'll tell them about the
attendant tax increases and the economic
hampering and talk about the inflation
you'll talk about the fact that the
national debt is going up and then they
start to get a little bit less sanguine
about each one of these individual
programs so what you're going to hear is
propaganda from the media about how what
we really need is universal child care
and what we really need is a
full-fledged increase in the earned
income tax credit which really is not an
earned income tax credit it is it is
really a disincentive for marriage
that's according to mitt romney and
marco rubio both of them are in favor of
the earned income tax credit as a
general rule
now you're going to hear about all the
wonders and glories of these programs
and the media are going to minimize all
the costs of the programs by saying all
the rich people are going to bear it
when in reality everyone is going to
bear it because the economy is
completely interlaced when your boss
gets taxed that gets passed down to you
just as when your company is profitable
it tends to raise wages
but the democrats don't believe that and
so they're going to run full forward on
this thing
the the real campaign that democrats are
going to try and carry forward however
and i don't think it's going to work
because again they do have total power
there's a case to be made and one of the
worst things that has happened for the
democrats is that the democrats actually
won those senate seats in georgia
because now people expect them to do
stuff but then the stuff that they are
expected to do people don't like very
much joe biden is trying to say that the
republicans are really bad for not
raising the debt limit
and he's saying that this is this is
just half of it is democrats deliver the
other half is republicans obstruct
here's joe biden who man just every day
he looks worse and worse and he really
just looks decrepit at this point
we're not expecting republicans to do
their part they made it clear from the
beginning
we tried asking to no avail
we're just asking them not to use
procedural tricks to block us from doing
the job that they won't do
meteor is henda is headed to crash into
our economy
democrats are willing to do all the work
stopping it
republicans just have to let us do our
job
just get out of the way
you don't want to help save the country
get out of the way
so you don't destroy it
if you want republicans are going to
destroy the country if they don't vote
for an increase in the debt ceiling by
the way democrats can do it without
republican approval all they have to do
is add in the debt ceiling increase into
the reconciliation bill that's all they
have to do
the problem for the democrats is that
they don't want to use the extra
reconciliation process they only get to
do it two or three times a year they
don't want to use the reconciliation
process on the increase in the debt
ceiling you know who knows this by the
way is joe biden back in 2004 for
example joe biden actually said he would
not vote to raise the debt limit
right this is from the congressional
record november 17 2004 quote i was not
able to participate in today's debate
and vote on the extension of the
national debt limit had i been here to
vote i would have cast a symbolic vote
against an extension of the debt limit
today's fiscal mess the transformation
of historic surpluses into record
deficits is not an accident it is the
inevitable outcome of policies that
consistently ignored evidence and
experience
many of us in congress argued we could
not afford to do everything and we
needed a fiscal policy that matched our
revenues with our expenditures we're
here today because that advice was
ignored those hard choices were ducked
and the bill for our decision will be
sent to our children and grandchildren
in the form of additional debt we'll
authorize today my symbolic vote against
raising the debt limit would have been a
protest of the policies that brought us
to this point and a demand that we
change course senator joe biden november
17 2004 but now if republicans say the
exact same thing to joe biden this means
that they are ready to watch a meteor
hit planet earth
but again all of this is really just a
distraction from the fact that there's
this large intranasian warfare going on
inside the democratic party joe biden
for his part is trying to pretend that
the timeline doesn't matter yesterday he
was he was gruff with people saying it
doesn't matter when we pass it it could
be in six days six hours six months or
six years we'll eventually pass this
thing i'm telling you we're gonna get
this done
[Music]
it doesn't matter when
it doesn't matter whether it's in six
minutes
six days or six weeks
we're gonna get it done
all righty so
the big problem again is that on the one
hand you have cinema and mansion who
basically held to their position now on
the other hand you have the progressives
or just going after them hammer and
tongs and what's interesting is to watch
as the democrats really do try to game
the system when i talk about gaming the
accounting system one of the things
democrats will typically do when it
comes to a giant bill like this is they
will use provisions in order to lower
the the estimated amount of debt that
aren't real so for example they will say
that a program kicks in in five years
and then they'll only estimate the cost
out to 10 years when the program
continues beyond the 10-year limit or
they'll say that a program begins in
and sun sets in 2027 knowing full well
that once a program has been established
congress will likely vote to extend the
program
and this is why james clyburn for
example from south carolina is why he's
been saying that we need to stop talking
about tenure numbers at all instead we
should probably just you know we should
probably just
put these systems in place for a small
period of time and then we should
pretend as though they're not going to
have outlandish costs down the road
we need to stop talking about
these 10-year numbers
that's what got people to either uh
whack they don't realize
that when you use that 3.5 number you're
talking about 10 years
people think in terms of budgeting for
one two three and sometimes five years
well unless it's your house mortgage you
don't take in terms beyond that
oh okay well you don't have to think
about terms beyond that because that
would actually require us to you know
use some forethought bottom line in all
of this joe biden decided he was going
to side with the progressives the only
thing that has stood in the way of joe
biden getting his progressive dreams
done is mansion and cinema no less a
personage than alexander ocasio-cortez
has claimed joe biden as one of their
own here is aoc talking about how they
have now essentially borged joe biden
and he is now a member of the sanders
crew
i think that president biden has been a
good faith partner to the entire
democratic party he is in fact a
moderate and we disagree on certain
issues
but
he he reaches out and he actually
tries to understand our perspective and
that is why i am fighting for his agenda
with the build back better app
so it's fun to watch joe biden who's now
been completely hijacked by the radical
left to the extent that he is now giving
the go-ahead to the most radical members
of the radical left now remember we've
been told that joe biden is moderate and
the democratic party is a party of
moderates we were told that the only
people who are into norm breaking are
the people on the right right donald
trump was a guy who's going to violate
norms he's all about norm violation
shattering the norms and there are some
people who celebrated that okay joe
biden shattered norms barack obama
shattered norms the dirty little secret
of american politics is that when you
grant all power to the executive branch
pretty quickly norms begin to be
shattered and when the american people
are
willing to run roughshod over norms to
get to utopia those norms end up being
trampled you know joe biden was captain
norms when he was in the senate right he
was he was the guy who was working
across the aisle and and he was the one
who was upholding the filibuster
knowledge now he's talking about
shattering the filibuster now he is
talking about how the democrats need to
ram through every deal without any
bipartisan support okay this reared its
ugliest head yesterday when protesters
follow christian cinema who's the
senator from arizona who again is sort
of the democratic john mccain in all of
this protesters follow kirsten cinema
into the bathroom here's a little bit of
video what that looked like
we need a buildback better plan right
now
we we're not gonna absorb
we need solutions in the build that
better plan need has the solutions
we knocked on doors for you to get you
elected and just how we got you elected
we can get you out of office if you
don't support what you promised us we
need seven million citizenship for seven
million we need the bell button
um i'm just going to uh point out here
that i it is my personal belief that
everyone ought to be able to poop in
peace this is my personal belief i want
to live in america where we can all take
a dump in privacy and peace if that's
too much for you well
you can find plenty of left-wing
programs that will tell you differently
i was told that women's spaces were
sacred spaces apparently not if you're
going to vote in favor of a bipartisan
infrastructure act but not in favor of a
3.5 trillion dollar spending act now the
part of this that's amazing is how much
kind of soft support the protesters
receive for following christian
sentiment to a bathroom
imagine republicans following christian
cinema into a bathroom there have been
talk of rape culture there have been
talk of the the fears that women have to
experience when they go into a public
restroom of of assault that these are
private spaces
but when it's left as following kirsten
sent him into a bathroom very different
story we'll get to that in just one
moment first let's talk about a simple
fact one way to get yourself in serious
financial trouble is to take out a
credit card and then just keep spending
on it without paying back the initial
amount you do that and you can find
yourself really behind the eight ball
what you need to do is consolidate that
credit card debt you can do that with a
credit card consolidation loan from
lightstream rates start at 4.98 apr with
autopay and excellent credit plus the
rate is fixed so it will never go up
over the life of the loan
you can get a loan from 5 000 to 100 000
there are absolutely no fees you can
even get your money as soon as the day
you apply
lightstream believes that people with
good credit deserve a better loan
experience that is exactly what they
deliver just for my listeners apply
right now you get a special interest
rate discount and save even more the
only way to get that discount is to go
to lightstream.com
shapiro that is
l-i-g-h-t-s-t-r-e-a-m dot com slash
shapiro lightstream dot com slash
shapiro subject to credit approval rates
range from four point nine eight percent
apr to nineteen point nine nine percent
apr they include a zero point five zero
percent auto pay discount lowest rate
requires excellent credit terms and
conditions apply offers are subject to
change without notice visit
lightstream.com shapiro for more
information that's lightstream.com
shapiro okay so the protesters follow
kirsten cinema into the bathroom and joe
biden is asked about this yesterday now
you would imagine that joe biden
remember he ran for office on the basis
of he was a moral person who was going
to restore the soul the nation no more
norms violations back to norms back to
conciliatory language back to unity
joe biden was asked about people
following christian cinema into the
bathroom and uh here were his rather
tepid remarks
senator cinema last night was chased
into a restroom do you think that those
tactics are crossing a line
i don't think they're appropriate
tactics but it happens to everybody
from
the only people it doesn't happen to are
people who have secret service stand
around them um so it's it's it's part of
the process
it's part of the process it's part of
the process it's inappropriate but it
happens to everybody and it's part of
the process does it though
does it really happen to everybody and
is the response from the president of
the united states the same way
it's amazing what sort of norm violation
is considered totally
okay or unworthy of further comment by
the democratic establishment what sort
of norm violation is deeply worthy of
comment by the establishment if tucker
carlson does a segment about military
uniforms for pregnant pilots that is
worthy of the worst sort of ire from the
federal government but if a sitting
united states senator is followed into
the bathroom by protesters
then that is worthy of a shrug a little
bit of a you know it happens whatever
again it it is incredible the sort of
treatment to which the the democrats
believe that people ought to be
subjected so long as they are on the
wrong side of a political issue she's a
democratic senator this is not even
republican but this goes all the way
back to the trump administration right
this goes back to the notion that if you
have the wrong sorts of views then you
ought to be browbeaten if you have the
wrong sorts of views then you ought to
be run out of restaurants like sarah
huckabee sanders
if you have the wrong sort of views you
ought to be intimidated in life like
this kristen cinema will be fine she's a
sitting united states senator
but the problem is that this sort of
attitude bleeds down to pretty much
everything if you have the wrong views
in american life you can be bullied out
of your job you can be ostracized from
your social community you can be treated
like garbage and a lot of people will
just kind of shrug and go oh well you
know you deserved it you had the wrong
sorts of views
that's really really ugly stuff and
unfortunately you saw a lot of blue
checks on twitter yesterday who are
basically talking up that sort of
position
and most famously jezebel which is of
course a radical left side
they put up a piece titled absolutely
holy christian cinema outside of her
bathroom stall
the senator is holding all of us back
and some of her most vulnerable
constituents are rightfully sick of it
this is by a columnist named ashley
reese quote the effectiveness of certain
kinds of protests will always be up for
debate so naturally a group of activists
pursuing senator kirsten cinema around
arizona state university campus over the
weekend and controversially somehow
briefly following cinema into a public
restroom to note that their family
members were deported is bound to prompt
some pearl clutching
on sunday social justice organization
living united for change in arizona
uploaded a video of activists asking
cinema to defend her opposition to
president biden's build back better act
democrats at large support the bill but
mansion and cinema do not
it's no wonder her constituents who
don't understand what the f she's doing
any better than the rest of us are
piping mad mad enough to pester her
after she finished teaching a class at
asu
lucha's video shows a group of activists
waiting outside cinema's classroom when
she emerges they ask if they could talk
to her briefly about the importance of
buildback better she said actually i'm
heading out and then she went down to a
bathroom we knocked on doors for you to
get elected said an activist named
blanca and just how he got you elected
we can get you out of office if you
don't support what you promised us cue
the sounds of toilets flushing
apparently the only thing not right was
following cinema into the bathroom
just wow just terrible just terrible
and how could you know
how could people be upset that this
would happen again so jinsaki yesterday
she tried to walk this back because even
some of the members of the body
administration are like this is a little
much so here's gensake trying to walk
this back a little bit
what happened this weekend was that her
classroom her students uh and and the
safe and intellectually stimulating
environment she's worked to create
during the years she's teaching it at
asu was breached that's inappropriate
and unacceptable and i think the context
of what happened here is important
despite the fact that of course we stand
for the president stands for the
fundamental right of people to protest
to object to criticize
as they often do outside of the gates of
the white house
okay so
the question for the democratic party is
going to be whether they actually stand
up to this sort of stuff because
remember we can pretend that this is
sort of an isolated incident but
main large parts of the democratic party
last year we're fine with people burning
down entire cities
and they we spent an entire year
pretending that riots weren't happening
in america's major cities so that the
media and democrats could pretend that
the protests over george floyd's death
had not in fact morphed into riots
meanwhile kamala harris the current
president of the united states uh vice
president i make the mistake the same
mistake job makes
vice president kamala harris is tweeting
out bail funds for for people who are
burning things down in places like
minnesota
so when we talk about norm violation and
rule breaking and where we go from here
we have to understand that if the nor in
many cases the norm violation is
happening inside the house and it has
now hijacked many of the people who used
to be considered moderates including joe
biden
and that is very scary for the future of
the country it matters an awful lot more
than how much money we spend in the next
month or so and that matters an awful
lot but i'll tell you what matters even
more is the fact that we have now
reached the point in american politics
where huge swaths of the american people
are just like you can do whatever you
want to do so long as it helps you
achieve the purpose you want to achieve
that is a recipe for the country falling
apart
and meanwhile
yesterday's big story is that facebook
had gone dark so facebook went dark for
about six hours yesterday and um
the facebook stock dropped it apparently
was some sort of hack
facebook and instagram were down for
some amount of hours yesterday
and this prompted a lot of talk about
facebook and it's evil this was also
prompted by a facebook whistleblower
named francis hogan who was on 60
minutes this is all in preparation for a
democratic full frontal assault on
facebook this facebook whistleblower was
talking about how instagram in
particular
had done internal research and they
found that shock of shocks teenage girls
were not doing well after using
instagram
now this has been true of pretty much
everything in media for as long as i've
been alive it turns out the research
shows that girls looking at glossy
magazines like cosmopolitan not
particularly good for self-image
that any sort of chat room for girls any
sort of interconnection for teenage
girls that is outside of sort of the
interpersonal
really is not great for mental health
but francis hoggin over at facebook is
now a whistleblower and she's a
whistleblower because there's an attempt
right now by democrats to basically take
facebook down a peg
the story of facebook is kind of
fascinating in the sense that it used to
be celebrated by the left now it has
become
persona non grotto uh enemy number one
for the left we'll explain that in just
one moment first let us talk about a
simple fact
and that is now right now it's a very
difficult time to hire if you're an
employer you would have thought well
look at all these people who are
unemployed i mean that's a huge pool of
people to choose from but right now
actually there are more job openings
than people who are actually seeking the
jobs this means you need the best and
this is where zip recruiters invite to
apply comes in it gives you the hiring
manager the power to pick your favorites
from top candidates and right now you
can try it for free at ziprecruiter.com
dailywire how does invite to apply work
well when you post a job on zip
recruiter they send you the most
qualified people for your job
then you can easily review the
candidates and invite your top choices
to apply for your job lauren webb svp of
talent acquisition form in dula health
raves about zip workers invites to apply
she says i love that feature if a much
higher follow through rate if i invite
candidates it's easy for me it's easy
for them in fact according to zip
recruiters internal data jobs where
employers use zip recruiters invite to
apply get on average two and a half
times more candidates which helps make
for a faster hiring process see for
yourself just go to this exclusive web
address ziprecruit.com
d-a-i-l-y-w-i-r-e to try zip recruiter
for free at
daily wire ziprecruiter.com
crew is indeed the smartest way to hire
okay so
again facebook went down yesterday and
that was kind of the big news but the
really big news is the coordinated
assault on facebook that is now
happening by democratic media and
politicians right it is a coordinated
assault
so to understand exactly what they're
doing facebook you have to understand
why facebook is a danger to the
democratic media complex so before 2016
facebook was a darling of the left
facebook had been used to great success
by barack obama in 2012 to mobilize all
the people who are going to vote for him
and to organize on the ground
facebook was this great godsend if you
go back and look at the media coverage
of facebook circa 2010 2011 2012 it was
very largely positive
and then something happened
something that happened was 2016. in
2016 donald trump won and when donald
trump won the left started to look for a
bogeyman they couldn't blame hillary
clinton they couldn't blame themselves
because they had convinced themselves
after 2012 that they had a durable never
to lose coalition they had a coalition
that would never be defeated electorally
again it was a coalition of the
dispossessed as african-americans for
barack obama and gays for barack obama
and hispanics for barack obama and
college-educated white liberals for
barack obama and this coalition when you
put them all together would never lose
again and then trump won
and for a brief moment in time in the
media there was this moment where they
said maybe we've missed something maybe
maybe we should go out and actually talk
to people instead of just considering
them evil horrific deplorables
and then the moment ended and they
decided no it can't be us who's we are
not wrong it's the children who are
wrong they're full principle skinner
from the simpsons
and they decided facebook was the
problem it had been facebook because if
facebook had not allowed all of this
dissemination of speech then presumably
hillary clinton would have won
and the way that they tried to cover for
the fact that they don't like freedom of
speech is by saying it was russian
interference on facebook now anybody who
actually looked at the stats on russian
interference on facebook understands
that the amount of actual dissemination
of russian material was extremely low
in the number of people actually
affected by russian disinformation the
senate did a full report and they were
putting up posts that were supposedly
the election shifters that had like a
thousand shares
yeah i had more shares from my facebook
page in a month than the entire
quote-unquote russian operation had in
over a year did i shift the entire
election in favor of donald trump of
course not it's very silly
but the media had to go with this
narrative because of course somebody had
to pay and it turns out that this
narrative also allowed the democratic
media establishment to try and
re-establish the monopoly on
informational dissemination that they
have been seeking since the rise of
alternative media
back in the 60s 70s
there were only a few daily papers that
were national the new york times the
washington post the wall street journal
there were only a couple of channels
that were national abc cbs nbc that's
where you got your news and there were
some local news channels that was it
and then with the rise of the internet
there came this ability to actually
critique and find alternative viewpoints
on on stories and sometimes find
alternative stories that were just not
covered by the media and this started to
eat into the media's market share
and so the media had two choices
and you've seen them take both one was
they could double down on their base
this is why the new york times is now
indistinguishable from salon.com
or
and right because they did both they
could attempt to crack down on the
methods of dissemination of information
and re-establish a media monopoly
and the way they would do that is by
cuddling facebook into suppressing
traffic from their competitors
the idea was if we can re-establish the
dominance of legacy media then things
will go back to normal it'll help us
it'll help us the media in our quest for
oligarchic control of informational
dissemination and market share
and it will help democrats because of
course all of the major outlets the
legacy media outlets in american life
those outlets all slant to the left and
coordinate pretty openly with the
democratic party it's the latest assault
on facebook as part of this understand
nobody in the media truly cares about
instagram and its effect on teenage
girls it's been the right largely it has
been very critical of kids using the
internet in these ways for years and
years and years and years i'm not
letting my kids use the internet until
they're essentially 18.
i have no intention of letting my kids
traffic around on instagram
with that said the democrats were kind
of happy with all this stuff right
social media is where you go for
approval when you're gender
transitioning social media is where you
go when you come out of the closet
social media is where you go when you're
looking for support for a fringe
left-wing position social media is where
you go when you're coordinating the
revolution
social media is how you escape the bonds
of your confinement at your home and
find a more sympathetic audience i mean
these are the the things that many
members of the left have been saying for
years and years and years now they're
very upset however with these exact same
services on a very selective level so
understand that the attack on instagram
really is not about instagram
right the left is not looking to crack
down on instagram in any serious way
what they're looking to do is force
zuckerberg and force facebook and force
all of these outlets into compliance
with what they believe should be the
informational dissemination rules
so the latest elements of this attack is
the facebook whistleblower francis hogan
so she was on 60 minutes talking about
how facebook had information that
instagram was damaging to teenage girls
and they continued to operate their
business
francis haugen plans to testify before
congress this week
she believes the federal government
should impose regulations
facebook has demonstrated they cannot
act independently facebook over and over
again has shown it uses profit over
safety it is subsidizing is paying for
its profits with our safety i'm hoping
that this will have had a big enough
impact on the world
that they get the fortitude and the
motivation to actually go put those
regulations into place
okay so understand the whistleblower
didn't whistle blow on anything
right she didn't actually give you any
information you didn't already have was
there anybody in america who is unaware
that instagram is damaging to teenage
girls has been known for quite a while
that again teenage girls online in a
wide variety of settings coordinating
with one another is very typically not a
wonderful thing teenage boys too right
teenagers generally coordinating with
each other like teenagers are not fully
developed brain wise and they tend to
make really dumb decisions and when
they're networked with each other the
decisions get dumber and dumber and this
has been true for a very long time but
why are the media playing this up so
facebook responded to this report from
60 minutes they said every day our teams
have to balance protecting the right of
billions of people to express themselves
openly with the need to keep our
platform a safe and positive place we
continue to make significant
improvements to tackle the spread of
misinformation and harmful content to
suggest we encourage bad content and do
nothing is just not true
they said we've invested heavily in
people and technology to keep our
platform safe and have made fighting
misinformation and providing
authoritative information a priority if
any research had identified an exact
solution to these complex challenges the
tech industry governments and society
would have solved them a long time ago
we have a strong track record of using
our research to inform changes to our
app
they say hosting hateful or harmful
content is bad for our community bad for
advertisers and ultimately bad for our
business our incentive is to provide a
safe meaningful experience for billions
of people who use facebook
and they say that the goal of meaningful
social interactions there's a metric
called meaningful social interactions
which is what they use to boost traffic
on particular posts they say the goal of
the meaningful social interactions
ranking change is in the name improve
people's experience by prioritizing
posts that inspire interactions
particularly conversations between
friends and family which research shows
is better for people's well-being and
deep prioritizing public content
research shows polarization's been
growing in the united states for a
decade
okay so again what facebook is saying
here because most of what this report
has been focused on in the media is
instagram but the other part of the
whistleblower talk is how facebook is
prioritizing quote unquote hate speech
and how they're incentivizing hate
speech okay understand why the media is
covering that they're saying that
because when they say hate speech what
they mean is shows they don't like and
people talking they don't like they mean
the new york post story on hunter biden
they mean shows like this one they mean
information disseminated from the daily
wire that is what they mean
and that is very clearly what they are
attempting to do it is no coincidence
that the facebook whistleblower is a
long time democratic donor
according to the national pulse she
donated 36 times to the democrats
including
to aoc
okay that is that is not a shock in any
way shape or form
it is also not a shock that the top
democratic operative bill burton is
advising the facebook whistleblower
according to the washington free beacon
she's getting strategic communications
guidance from a top democratic operative
burton is now deeply integrated with an
emerging infrastructure on the left
comprised of individuals and
organizations including the non-profit
center for humane technology seeking to
press facebook to more aggressively
police political content
in hogan's public testimony industry and
political insiders see a sophisticated
communications campaign intended to put
facebook on defense from a steady
trickle of leaked internal documents
that fueled a wall street journal
investigative series dubbed the facebook
files to the blockbuster 60 minutes
interview to congressional testimony
scheduled to begin on tuesday
hugging 60 minutes interview kicked off
a media feeding frenzy with the story
mentioned at least 200 times on cable
news since the segment aired
burton's involvement helping to manage
hogan's public debut suggests her
argument is part of a broader democratic
initiative this of course is exactly
true because remember the goal of the
democrats is to get facebook to crack
down on information that democrats do
not like
that is the goal
and it's coming from the white house by
the way this is coordinated here is jen
saki explaining that what this
whistleblower interview shows that
quote-unquote self-regulation isn't
working okay now as facebook says what
sort of regulation would actually work
here
right there there's it's very funny
there are people on the right who say
well you know we on the
left and the right we can agree that
facebook needs to be regulated okay what
you don't understand if you say that is
that the way that the write wants to
regulate facebook is by forcing facebook
to allow more content the way that the
left wishes to regulate facebook is by
forcing facebook to allow less content
that is a fundamental debate that is not
going to be bridged here here's jen saki
essentially calling for censorship
in our view this is just the latest in a
series of revelations about social media
platforms that make clear that
self-regulation is not working that's
long been the president's view and been
the view of this administration
they validate the significant concern
that the president lawmakers on both
sides of the aisle have expressed about
how social media giants operate and the
power they've amassed
okay understand that what this really is
is government control okay they're
looking for government control
margaret sullivan the columnist for the
washington post she says what we really
should be pushing for here is get ready
for it a new federal agency focused on
the digital economy hey more federal
government that'll be the solution
remember that part where it said
congress shall not abridge freedom of
speech remember that part yeah that's
that's gone we need a new federal agency
that is given the power to effectively
just slap any company that disseminates
information
that democrats don't like i guess it's
presumably the way this would work
the idea comes from none other than a
former fcc chairman tom wheeler who
maintains that neither his agency nor
the federal trade commission are nimble
or tech savvy enough to protect
consumers in a volatile and evolving
industry you need an agency that doesn't
say here are the rigid rules when the
rules become obsolete almost immediately
said wheeler
so if we really want to think about the
public interest in the fast-paced
digital world it will be necessary to
revise the quote cumbersome top-down
rule-making process that has been in
place since the industrial era wheeler
wrote in a harvard shorenstein center
paper
digital platforms like facebook and
google have become pseudo governments
that make the rules said wheeler so
instead what they need are a bunch of
people in government who don't actually
have to say what the rules are they can
just go around and do exactly what they
want
it's kind of an incredible thing that
they're calling for i mean they're
calling for for pretty much top-down
tyranny you know the rule of law
requires that you have easily
interpretable neutrally applicable rules
what's being called for by margaret
sullivan is a government agency that has
no rules but has nearly unlimited power
over this area of american life
now listen facebook has made its own bed
here in some ways because for years
facebook stood up to the left and then
facebook started to collapse to the left
i mean back in 2019 mark zuckerberg said
at georgetown university quote people no
longer have to rely on traditional
gatekeepers and politics or media to
make their voices heard that has
important consequences i understand the
concerns about how tech platforms have
centralized power but i actually believe
the much bigger story is how much these
platforms have decentralized power by
putting it directly into people's hands
and this is when zuckerberg was a big
free speech advocate
and then the left put so much pressure
on that facebook started to suppress
information
apparently in the belief that if they
were nice to the left the left would
leave them alone wrong
once the left's got its foot in the door
now the left is going to go the rest of
the way and they are going to go after
facebook and you know we on the right
again a lot of people on the right are
very skeptical of facebook i think that
skepticism is in many ways justified as
i'll discuss in a moment
but understand that if facebook gets
shut down or facebook gets restricted by
the federal government
the outlets that are going to suffer are
not the new york times or cnn or msnbc
all of the competitive brands
because those competitive brands have
been using facebook as a distribution
platform in new media
all these other platforms we're talking
about have been around for 30 years
daily wear has been around since 2015.
that's why there is a coordinated
campaign against the spigot if facebook
is the spigot the goal of the left is to
shut off the spigot your access to
information that's what this is really
about you don't have to love zuckerberg
to believe that you have to love
facebook to believe that you can be very
critical of facebook's willingness to
concede to exactly the people seeking to
shut off the spigot which we'll discuss
in a moment
but you gotta understand what exactly
they're trying to do because it is
perfectly obvious at this point we'll
get some more of this in just one second
first if you've been listening to the
show for a while you've probably heard
me talk about my helix mattress it is
the greatest mattress because it is made
just for me but now we have exciting
news helix has gone beyond the bedroom
and started making sofas they just
launched a new company called all form
they're making premium customizable
sofas and chairs shipped directly to
your door so what makes an all form sofa
really cool well for starters it's the
easiest way you can customize the sofa
using premium materials and at a
fraction of the cost of traditional
stores you can pick your fabric it is
spill stain scratch resistant the sofa
color the color of the legs sofa size
shape make sure it is perfect for you
and your home they've got arm chairs and
love seats all the way up to an
eight-seat sectional so there's
something for everybody and you can
always start small and buy more seats
later on if you want your all-form sofa
to grow and change with you when you
move for my family i picked out the
three-seat sofa with chase and the sand
color with espresso legs it is fabulous
and honestly it is the greatest sofa to
nap on it is i need a nap right now and
now that i'm thinking about it i really
want to go home and just climb on my
all-form sofa if getting a sofa without
trying it in store sounds risky don't
worry you get 100 days to decide if you
want to keep it that's more than three
months and if you don't love it they'll
pick it up for free and give you a full
refund they also have a forever warranty
literally for all time to find your
perfect sofa check out
allform.com and all form is offering 20
off all orders for our listeners at
allform.com
ben today go check them out alrighty
we'll get to more on this in just a
moment first
the legacy media has dominated the
podcast world until now our newest
podcast morning wire is here to bring
you the facts to start your day it's the
only daily news podcast that values your
time and the truth and while we're
working overtime to bring you the news
you need to know we need your help to
keep the facts trending toward number
one so please subscribe start listening
now to morning wire on apple spotify or
wherever you listen to podcasts leave a
five star review if you like what you
hear you're listening to the largest
fastest growing conservative podcast and
radio show in the nation
[Music]
okay so to understand exactly how much
facebook has already caved to the left
you have to kind of look at their new
standards so a few weeks ago facebook
put out a notice as to how they
distribute content their content
distribution guidelines so here at the
daily wire over the last year right just
before the election it became very clear
that facebook had changed its standards
and was now suppressing content we could
see it in our traffic stats we could see
how facebook had started to suppress our
traffic essentially and now they are
admitting exactly how they do this and
the way that they do this is by setting
standards that explicitly benefit the
legacy media and so there's a certain
irony to the legacy media now using that
as a as a foot in the doorway to just
ram through all the way and destroy
facebook wholesale
as always cowardice is met not with some
sort of conciliatory approval by those
who are seeking a concession cowardice
is met with abject humiliation if you
are a coward they will come and they
will destroy your business if you are a
coward and you give one inch to the left
the left will come in and they will
break you they will destroy what you
have built so facebook gave much more
than an inch
remember facebook's original pitch was
we are here to allow as many people as
possible to engage with as many sources
as humanly possible because you live in
a world of choice and this will allow
people to actually get access to
information and social networks they
otherwise would not have been a part of
and then facebook shifted in 2018 2019
2020 they started talking about their
responsibility to call out information
that they thought was bad not
information that was overtly false not
information that was so far outside the
overton window that it bordered on the
violent right not any of that they
decided they were going to call out
mainstream information and they were
going to suppress mainstream information
so long as that information came from a
non-approved political point of view and
now they're making that perfectly clear
right so here are their standards that
they admitted to having for the past
year
and this kind of stuff does affect
elections gang
what what did they do they said that
they were going to suppress content from
domains with limited original content
they said they're going to crack down on
content that quote contains a large
amount of content from other publishers
that has been copied or only slightly
modified usually for the purposes of
increasing web page volume and driving
traffic
now that is explicitly directed at
places that don't have massive
journalistic budgets
right because the reality is that most
sites rely on a certain amount of
aggregation in fact even the mainstream
media relies on a certain amount of
aggregation how many times have you seen
a story from the new york times
laundered into the washington post as a
rewrite of the new york times story it
happens all the time but facebook was
only going to crack down on one type of
site for this sort of activity
then facebook said they were going to
crack down on traffic rooted in fact
checked misinformation
so they downgraded quote content that
has been debunked as false altered or
partly false by nonpartisan third-party
fact-checking organizations who partner
with facebook and have been certified by
the international fact-checking
organization
so as we've deal as we've detailed
expansively on this show and at daily
wire fact-checking organizations who
have been approved by the so-called
international fact-checking network are
almost entirely left-wing propaganda
agencies dedicated to the upholding of
left-wing lies and the suppression of
right-wing truths
so if you say things that are true fact
checkers will very often suggest that
you have said something that is false
this sort of stuff happens like all the
time it will say that you are missing
context
they'll admit openly that what you're
saying is true in the body of the peace
and then they will say mixed their
rating will be mixed meanwhile if you're
a leftist and you say something overtly
false
like the cost of the
buildback better agenda is zero
they will say that it's mostly true
because it's covered by tax dollars
right the fact-checking organizations
are propaganda ali so basically facebook
outsourced to a bunch of left-wing
propaganda outlets the ability to
suppress traffic from anybody who
disagrees
facebook also said they would cut down
on quote-unquote inauthentic sharing
according to facebook link posts will be
reduced when they are shared a high
number of times and the majority of that
sharing comes from accounts that
recently and repeatedly engaged in
hyper-sharing content relative to the
average person who uses our service so
in other words if the most excited
people tend to retweet daily wire
articles or or repost them on facebook
then the content will be suppressed
you have to have the average joe
who may not be all that politically
aware or informed tweeting out stuff or
putting it up on facebook in order for
facebook to allow the traffic to
aggregate
facebook cut down
on traffic from links to domains and
pages with a high quote-unquote click
gap
according to facebook
they restricted quote links to websites
that receive a particularly
disproportionate amount of their traffic
directly from facebook compared to the
amount of traffic the websites received
from the rest of the internet this is a
perfect example of so-called regulatory
capture by the legacy media the legacy
media has existed for literally
over a century
they've built up this wellspring of
people who are subscribers and who click
on their stuff organically for those of
us who had to start our companies in the
last 10 years a lot a large amount of
our traffic comes from the place where
the eyeballs are facebook facebook is
now saying if too high a percentage of
your traffic comes from facebook we'll
crack down on your traffic
so we are explicitly cracking down on
the places that are new media in favor
of the places that are old media
it's like a billboard agency deciding to
reject advertisements from a startup
restaurant because too many customers on
a percentage basis are coming into the
restaurant based on the billboard rather
than coming in based on quote unquote
organic traffic that would obviously cut
very much in favor of legacy
organizations like mcdonald's or kfc and
not in favor of the new startup
restaurant that is simply trying to get
people to come in by using billboards
facebook says they're going to suppress
articles that are coming from quote
non-transparent authorship so if you use
a staff byline or if somebody uses a
pseudonym online to avoid the the
evil political climate we've created
where people are targeted in their homes
then they're going to crack down on that
and they cut down on posts from quote
unquote
broadly untrusted news publishers
what exactly is broadly untrusted how
exactly ought that to be decided
broadly untrusted according to facebook
means that you have to have people from
all sides of the political aisle would
say that they trust you who do you think
that's going to benefit that's not going
to benefit the new media or overt about
their their biases it's going to benefit
the old media who lie about them
hey and they said they were going to
suppress content that was borderline to
the community standards including
content that does not violate coven 19
or vaccine policies but which shares
misleading or sensationalized
information about vaccines in a way that
would be likely to discourage
vaccinations which means they really
should be cracking down on joe biden and
anthony fauci but instead they're
cracking down on the right the point
that i'm making here is that facebook
has already spent years attempting to
placate the left and now the left is
seeking to destroy facebook all the way
they're seeking to destroy facebook
wholesale
if you can't spot what it is they are
trying to do
you're gonna miss exactly why all of a
sudden there's all this information that
is coming out about facebook it has
nothing to do with the goodwill of the
media and the attempts to crack down on
bad behavior by massive social media
companies it's not about that it's about
cracking down on your ability to access
the information that you want by the
democrat media complex
in coordination with some insiders at
facebook itself already we'll be back
here later today with an additional hour
of content coming up soon the matt walsh
show airs at 1 30 pm eastern be sure to
check it out over at dailywire.com i'm
ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
elliot feld executive producer jeremy
boring our supervising producer is
mathis glover production manager pablo
wydowski associate producer bradford
carrington host producer justin barbour
the show is edited by adam sci events
audio is mixed by mike coromina hair and
makeup is by fabiola cristina production
assistant jessica kranz the ben shapiro
show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire
2021 on the matte wall show we talk
about the things that matter real issues
that affect you your family our country
not just politics but culture faith
current events all the fundamentals if
they matter to you come check out the
show